millions of Americans tune in each year
to what's been the most-watched TV event
in US history the Superbowl maybe your
team didn't make it but that's okay cuz
while two other teams you couldn't care
less about you get out on the field a
ton of other players off the field will
be winning and losing too and guess what
you might be one of them let's kick
things off with the Biggest Loser no not
the show but close enough your waistline
because apparently after Thanksgiving
Super Bowl Sunday is the biggest food
consumption day in the US we're talking
80 million avocados mashed up to make
your favorite guac that you'll be
dipping with more than 11 million pounds
of chips add that to the more than 1
billion chicken wings you'll stuff your
faces with and wash it down with a 325
million gallons of beer being guzzled
and you'll be looking and sounding like
this guy in no time but a shout-out to
the pizza delivery guys who'll be
earning major tips on what
single-handedly the biggest pizza
delivery day of the year
touchdown saturated fats your food
induced coma / hangover brings us to our
next loser your employers that's because
a whole bunch of you will be calling in
sick on Monday self diagnosed with Super
Bowl itis past years have seen him 1 and
a half million of you slackers come down
with it making Super Bowl Monday one of
the least productive days in the year oh
hello advertisers and game broadcasters
welcome to the winners table advertisers
you know damn well that you have a
captive audience of more than a hundred
million people who will actually watch
your commercials on this day and this
day only so I get why you ditched out
four and a half a million dollars for a
30-second spot and NBC should really be
thanking you for the 350 million dollars
in revenue they'll be getting from
broadcasting at all whenever there's
raging testosterone in the air women
tend to lose in this case the severely
underpaid NFL cheerleaders even though
they look this fly shaking their
pom-poms and what their mamas gave them
the average NFL cheerleader makes
anywhere from a whopping seventy to a
hundred and fifty dollars a game often
not even being paid for practice or
public appearances so in an industry
making almost 10 billion dollars a year
you have team employees not making
enough to even pay the basic bills
touchdown patriarchy you think hosting
the Super Bowl in your city
means super money at least that's how
the NFL hyped it up but no cities can
lose here also one study that looked at
25 Super Bowls found that the economic
impact of the game for the host cities
comes out to only a tenth of the amount
promised by the NFL add up the cost of
additional security clean up transit and
everything else and you've got a big fat
bill for the city and its residents this
year the mayor of host City Glendale
Arizona complained so much about the
ever increasing price tag you didn't
even get invited to the game now that's
unnecessary roughness this brings us to
our final and most obvious winner the
NFL which rakes in close to ten billion
dollars a year making it the most valued
sports league in the world and yet it
somehow manages to operate as a
nonprofit that doesn't pay taxes or its
cheerleaders apparently but this
benevolent nonprofit does pay its
Commissioner Roger Goodell an astounding
44 million dollar salary despite the
numerous scandals under his watch sure
soon there you have it folks the winners
and losers whenever the Super Bowl comes
around but one thing is for sure we all
win if Marshawn Lynch keeps giving those
interviews yeah the leaked footage of
Ray Rice's assault sparked an onslaught
of shock disgust and even judgment of
janae